la sorpresa più di merda è stata quella
che ho fatto io al mio ex deciso bene di
fargli una sorpresa a casa lo trovo a
letto con la mia migliore amica un trans
con la parrucca e insieme a loro c'era
anche un cinese vestito da quota inutile
dirti che mi sono immediatamente andata
e non ho mai più voluto vedere né lui la
mia ormai ex migliore amica nel cinese
aveva una signorina sì ma per il bene
della scienza tu fai dato migliore
michele di ci senti che conte non
parlerò mai più
ma che cosa facevano quel transeco il
cinese vestiti da fuoco cosa faceva
cucinava aveva una padella col cappello
nascente era la mistery box
magari era un semplice aperitivo e
ferrara un semplice aperitivo grazie al
recco in casa spesa che ha fatto a lui a
lei
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema di oggi
è sorprese di merda
questo tema è stato suggerito da lucido
orlando è piaciuto molto e quindi ho
pensato che effettivamente forse le
persone avessero qualcosa da dire e ho
pensato quindi di prendere la persona
alla quale io ho fatto forse la più
grande sorpresa di questa donna vi è una
vita felice e spensierata ha 22 anni è
un certo punto sono arrivato io sto
parlando di mia madre
ciao ciao a tutti bene bene è piaciuto
all'intero spettacolo lei non ha fiatato
minimamente lasciato che dicessi tutto
quanto ma io ormai alle spalle
abbastanza larghe per sopportare tutto
ciò siamo un pò storti federica si è
così stata bella ma sedi di allora
diciamo che quando nei residenti società
una per malati ma anche maroni collette
mai capito da brutti per tutto di
concezione ti senti ti prego parti che
parli di sistema suicidato ti prego lei
si è vista come una ragazza ma quando si
è seduta sulle sue gambe ha capito che
c'era una sorpresina sì però a mio
parere sta esalando l'ultimo respiro ti
prego per un giorno
diciassettesimo compleanno deciso di
organizzare un pranzo è la mia casa in
campagna
i miei amici hanno la brillante idea che
per consegnarmi regalo devono farmi
allontanare la scusa per farmi
allontanare stata che non di un mio
amico aveva avuto un incidente e dovevo
correre nella casa di campagna a fianco
la mia per prestare soccorso
mentre loro cercavano di raccogliere
questi questi soldi alla tutti un tono
dimesso oggi sti ragazzi non sono
frizzanti mamma questo qui è andato a
correre per per il nonno che è sembrato
che sta seguendo
che devo dire una call con l'allegria o
piccola gioia nel cuore quella che è
entrata in camera e vedrete ha visto il
ragazzo con un trans la mia canzone se
questi sono proprio doveva dirci
qualcosa con un jingle sotto no vabbè in
effetti no
ok possiamo andare avanti che questa
insensibilità io ne sono uscita mai
sentiamo ora il crollo di questa persona
ciao lavorate racconto i soldi dovesse
cessare pratica cinque anni di nella
zona
a un certo punto scoprono cose non mi
piacciono
la lascio non pro cosi solo giallo sulla
vita di tutto che settimana mi trovo a
lui con un vassoio di palle di cocco e
ricoperte di cioccolato melo da e parte
ma la feroce no non ho capito già nella
gialle ma che cos'è mai digeriti facile
fare le mie blocco
infatti mentre cioè mani siamo 7
cammelli per il tuo aspetta modificare
la voce perché perché sentirà delle cose
terribili
la mia vorrei che facciamo parlare con
la cucina
perché di tale da farmi penso che
controlla tutti nemici tanto che c'era
bisogno di dirlo con un piano della
festa anzi per fortuna ho detto di
modificare la voce vuol dire che sarà
comunque uscito iti più interne ma
mettere la carta tutti 6 ubriacato di
cui tutti questi silenzi queste pause ma
poi non accorciate non manteniamo un
vile 50 minuti ma dove le persone
possano prendere una spillatrice proprio
sta proprio graffetta si allena alla
seria arrivarmi così la mia sorpresa è
stata i miei 18 anni dove festeggio con
tutti i parenti in casa mia madre la
brillante idea di presentarsi come una
torta con stampata una tipa nuda che si
sgrillettarvi camente il nuovo sito
cliccami tutta non contenta sempre
davanti a tutti i parenti mi obbliga a
fare foto da porco su questa torta il
problema che io ancora non avevo fatto
coming out e quindi il mio imbarazzo era
immenso ti dico solo che resta te stessa
poi sono dichiarato e mia madre continua
a raccontare questa storia della torta
amici e parenti
non lo so lei si scassa le risate ma in
quel momento io volevo una botola per
sprofondare io e pervenire un tiramisù
forma di mamma sai che quasi quasi le
due sorprese di impari discono anche a
norma che fa la torta con la foto della
tipa dei reali meravigliosi a un certo
punto è fatto un paio di mutande
gianluigi non delle mutande di dolce
gabbana sloggi e ritorni degli alloggi
enrico cosa che hai fatto ho voluto
dimenticare gabriella paghetta di
superman che già aveva ea me un libro il
secondo libro di una saga
cioè noi come regalato il primo
collegato il secondo il primo
evidentemente c'e la rally ma stai
scherzando comunque diciamolo sloggi
nuova marca del momento
fa sempre piacere ma è come un diamante
i master oggi e per sempre sopravviva
qualsiasi rigata ciao hero fissata
volevo tantissimo avere un cane una
volta mio fratello è tornato a casa e
poi ho sentito abbaiare dal salotto per
cui sono corsa pensando di essere
comprato un pane e invece mi avevano
preso un peluche di un husky gigante
tipo di musei reali sembra vero ma il
bambino il cane
il cane il cane sembra pero che questo
qui sembra vero allora questa è una vera
persona cioè avevo pensato bene di fare
una sorpresa a mia madre che teneva
tantissimo ha fatto che mi laureo se
vieni non le ho detto nulla che
frequentavo l'università sono arrivato a
laurearmi
gliel'ho detto qualche giorno prima
della tesi e lei avuto un infarto per la
felicità
per questo tra vissuto due anni fa
rientro da scuola
mamma mia mi ha preparato una festa a
sorpresa entrò in camera e mito tutti i
miei amici tra cui mio fidanzato con un
foglietto in mano
vedo mia madre entrare con il microfono
mia madre cantari di gamma in modo
pessimo
leo mentre i miei amici faccio un certo
sottofondo mia madre iniziava ad urlare
come una gallina quando l'asta reggiano
e giurò volevo scherzar la cev ha
iniziato un pezzo lirico di auguri si
con tutti i suoi amici
allora di sottofondo una grande regalo a
ragazzi voi tutti quanti che laguna blu
esatto penso che vi è niente
praticamente era il mio compleanno
facevo 25 anni ed una mia amica mi
regala un poncho del milan io out ratio
è bellissimo il problema è che le dà per
un bambino di 10 anni aveva una storia
distanza quindi con non ci tenevamo
molto proprio per questo cercavo di
essere un po più carina soprattutto
quando ci saremmo visti non è che tutti
i giorni mi mette o da corsa lui si è
presentato a casa mia di sorpresa una
sera ha scoperto che sono ieri non è una
cosa di cui vergogna chi vuol dire
perché è evidente perché se intende
vista ragazza no non è grido di lei
nella situazione
carina perfettina un giorno è andato
diretto ad un peluche
stavo per compiere 17 anni è una
settimana prima cerca ovviamente di
estrapolare qualche informazione sul mio
regalo ogni volta mio padre parlava di
questo regalo come se fosse un qualcosa
di epico arriva il giorno del mio
compleanno ne arriva questa volta che io
apro velocemente
rimango delusissima perché trovo una
tavoletta di legno con sopra inciso
nulla mi spaventa io ho una figlia tutto
spavento invece tutti gli hotel che un
padre
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
ma grazie per essere stata ospite di
trieste casa mia e mi diverto sempre ma
anche perché penso che non ci sia
nessuno anche perché penso che nessuno
ci ascolta
insomma non ci sia nessuno che verrà
appare colpita si fa forza e
naturalmente come sempre vi invito a
farmi sapere qua sotto se ci sono dei
temi che vorreste vedere subito buttata
e ammettere i like a quelli che vi
piacciono di più in modo da capitò fate
sentire in classifica e permettermi di
capire quali piacciono di più perciò
posso salutare di te ne prego
ciao a tutti mi sento sotto esame con te
non mi spiegavo posso salutare saluta
andiamo
va bene a ponte causes and my lai mentre
ascoltiamo questo messaggio boglione che
enrico se ci sta vedendo visto che fa il
montaggio mangia tipo un effetto
speciale pazzesco il mio vantaggio già
col fuoco ha così non devi usare il solo
dopo mi fa capire gialla
il bello di questo speciale